[Música]
mi nombre es leon mendieta tengo 23 años
estudió música en el conservatorio
manuel de falla doy clases de guitarra y
de teoría musical
desde chico me gustó siempre la música
me gustaba tararear cantar
percutir todo siempre fue muy inquieto
[Música]
empecé como casi todos tocando flauta
dulce en el colegio
en tercer grado entré a una escuela de
pedagogía waldorf
esa escuela me gustaba mucho porque me
hacía conectar realmente con mi parte
artística
en esa en ese colegio había una orquesta
que también tocaba la flauta dulce pero
a la par iba aprendiendo a tocar
guitarra que era el instrumento que más
me atraía
empecé clases de guitarra a los 9 años
compartiendo una misma clase con un
amigo las veces que empecé y dejé por
cuestiones económicas ya no me acuerdo
recién empecé a tener una constancia a
estabilizarme cuando entré en el
conservatorio
cuántos de nosotros soñamos alguna vez
con tener una banda
creo que acá seguramente varios bueno la
mía iba a ser de rock por eso recuerdo
como uno de los momentos más felices
cuando a mis 15 años me regalaron una
guitarra eléctrica una guitarra sg
esa guitarra me la regaló mi viejo que
unos años después de que me la regalara
me confesó me dijo la verdad que me puse
mal
no te puede hacer las fiestas legales
solamente una guitarra
y la verdad me sentí muy triste
para mí fue algo gracioso y hasta
sorpresivo ya que para mí la guitarra
era el regalo perfecto y había sido muy
feliz de alguna forma ese regalo se
convirtió en mi refugio
sin embargo no puedo decir que ese año
así haya sido muy feliz ya que empezaba
en la fiesta de 15 y la verdad que como
día verá la fiesta de 15 es la edad que
tus amigos tus amigos te decían acordate
que este fin de semana es el cumpleaños
de tal
y te torturaban hasta el último día para
ver si vas a ir bueno en realidad yo lo
veía como una tortura porque odiaba a ir
ponía excusas pero bueno uno no puede
poner excusas siempre no
y para mí ir a las fiestas era algo de
suma fuerza me tenía que vestir formal
lo odiaba la verdad vestirme formal lo
mío no era vestirme así a mí me gustaba
estar de jean una remera y una zapatilla
bien cómoda
hace pocos años atrás mi hermano mira
una foto que estábamos los dos
vestidos formales para ir al 15 de la
hija de una amiga de mi mamá y me dice
que facha la de los 20 malos
estuve buena ese día
y yo le dije sí
para vos
porque no era justo el del vestido
y si tuviesen puesto a vos el vestido
[Música]
creo que ese ejemplo fue uno de los más
claros para que mi hermano entendiera
realmente cómo me sentía
la época de la adolescencia suele ser
bastante difícil para cualquier persona
es el momento en que las hormonas nos
van modificando nuestra imagen corporal
en mi caso me empecé a sentir menos
cómodo con mi sexo biológico ya que el
cuerpo se va desarrollando de la manera
opuesta con la cual yo me identificaba
con la cual yo me auto percibía
viví toda esa época como un conflicto
con mucha incomodidad
escribiendo para esta charla me sentía
angustiado ya que me acordé de cosas que
hice por obligación familiar por
obligación escolar social
todo el tiempo estaba buscando la forma
de salirme de mí mismo de no ser
consciente y de no pensar
por ejemplo
me acuerdo que cuando era chico me bese
con un montón de pibes para disimular y
que no se dieran cuenta que me gustaban
las chicas
de hecho se pensaban que era atrevido
porque me da beso con cualquiera
[Música]
y ese razonamiento no
recuerdo estudiar teatro y no poder
siquiera interpretar el papel de un
hombre porque me sentía perseguido
el teatro jugar
pero no podía jugar siempre hacer el
hombre ya que tenía miedo a la mirada de
los otros guau que me preguntaran porque
siempre los papeles masculinos
pero tampoco me sentía cómodo
interpretando papeles de mujer ya que no
era que era una vez esporádicamente por
un papel eventual sino que era siempre
lo mismo
así que bueno
la adolescencia es difícil especialmente
si no encajas en el molde
a los 15 pese a una chica le conté a mi
mamá me apoyó
le fui contando a mis amigas
les dije que era bisexual porque no era
tan chocante
es más lo dije recién cuando una amiga
mía dijo que le gustaban las mujeres
después les dije que les había dicho que
era bisexual para que no me cuestionen
tanto a lo sumo pensaban que estaba
confundido momentáneamente pero no
cuestionaban
qué lindo hubiera sido que mi
adolescencia hubiera desarrollado dentro
de un ambiente fuera de cuestionamientos
de prejuicios
las sexualidades e identidades de género
distintas a las estereotipadas son
difíciles de asumir y enfrentar
socialmente
hoy en día es un poco más fácil porque
se habla del tema
pero hasta hace poco no se podía
siquiera decir libremente que te
gustaban las chicas y las chicas o los
chicos y las chicos porque recibí hace
un bullying tremendo
si eras homosexual pero tenía que
guardar
yo creo que es más perdón incluso hasta
los 90 la homosexualidad era considerada
una enfermedad
yo creo que es muy importante la
libertad que hay hoy en día
pero de todas maneras hay que seguir
trabajando cada vez más para que uno
pueda crecer y desarrollarse en un
ambiente libre de discriminación más
inclusivo y de menos odio e ignorancia
hacia lo que no está estereotipado hacia
lo diverso
la transexualidad es un tabú depende en
el ambiente en el que te crías te lo
tenéis más lejos o más cerca
en mi caso estaba bastante lejano no ha
hablado fuera de lo común
los padres crean ciertas expectativas y
es a partir de ahí como crían a sus
hijos
cuando el hijo hija o hijo porque
también existen las identidades que son
no binarias que son las identidades que
no se identifican ni con el género
femenino ni con el género masculino
cuando esas identidades no cumplen con
ese estereotipo formado en la cabeza de
los padres
es difícil
desde la concepción los padres fueron
haciendo planes y proyecciones
pero qué sucede cuando esta proyección
no se cumple
la familia es muy importante en el
proceso de acompañamiento de una persona
transgénero
muchos abusan de drogas o terminan
suicidándose porque piensan que está mal
lo que les pasa
en mi caso el cambio no fue de un día
para el otro
me fui vistiendo más masculina mente o
trataba de vestirme de forma neutra y
como me movía en el ambiente del rock me
ponía un chino una remera y pasaba
me gustaban cosas de hombre y no me las
compraba
una está determinado siempre por la
sociedad
uno en realidad solo busca ocupar un
lugar en el cual sentirse cómodo
el mayor cambio fue cuando leí la
historia de un chico trans
fue el día que caía en la cuenta de lo
que me estaba pasando
hace casi dos años
digo caí porque nunca supe ponerlo en
palabras
[Música]
quizás sí cuando era chico hubieran
salido a la luz estos temas en vez de
ser un tabú
si hubiera habido una visibilización
como la que hoy se ve cada día más
quizás lo hubiera podido poner en
palabras antes
la historia de este chico trans que leí
fue a través de la noticia de que había
ido al programa de susana giménez y que
se había sentido incómodo por como lo
habían tratado el tema y que lo habían
tratado sin informarse adecuadamente
desde el desconocimiento
en la nota de hablar de cosas de su vida
de anécdotas de cómo se había sentido
con su transición entre varias cosas
me sentí totalmente identificado
la cabeza me va mil
me preguntaba no estaré confundido
es esto lo que realmente me pasa
para mí era algo sumamente nuevo
por primera vez todo lo que había
sentido se había reflejado en alguien
más
hasta ese momento yo me sentía el único
con esos sentimientos ya que nunca había
estado cerca ni había escuchado sobre
los chicos trans
sobre chicas trans si había escuchado si
había visto pero sobre hombres trans no
nunca me sentí cómodo con mi cuerpo
siempre siempre siempre de 10 mis
caderas no me sentía bien sexualmente
tampoco el rol que cumplía
hay una diversidad inmensa que yo no
conocía
a partir de esta historia comencé a
preguntarme si nací biológicamente mujer
estaría bien cambiar mi biología
tenía dudas desde muchos lugares hasta
incluso religiosos
así que en ese momento me plantee que
quería tener alguna señal para ver si lo
que estaba pensando sintiendo
estaba bien estaba mal
mi primer señal fue enterarme por una
propaganda por televisión que se había
inaugurado la primera casa trans del
país situada en capital federal buenos
aires en esta casa ofrecen contención
información testeos capacitación entre
otras cosas para personas transgéneros
la primera vez que fui a casa trans lo
primero que me preguntaron fue cómo es
tu nombre
no sabía qué responder
y les dije pero mi nombre o el que hice
en mi documento
entonces me respondieron con qué nombre
te gustaría que te llamemos les dije
león
yo ya venía pensando un nombre
yo no estaba decidido pero no les iba a
decir mi nombre anterior
siempre me gustaron los leones por su
fortaleza
de hecho tengo una tatuado
en casa trans empecé a hablar con un
chico y mientras hablaba con él y le
contaba lo que me estaba pasando lo
interrumpía a su hijo y él le decía para
león quédate quieto león
ahí descubrí que nn se llamaba león
también
segunda señal
poco tiempo antes había ido a ver una
banda y de casualidad estacionamos el
auto justo en la puerta de casa trans
que yo aún no conocía era de noche la
persiana estaba baja y no había llegado
a leer ni el cartel
el día que voy a averiguar sobre
armonización me dicen justo ahora las 17
empieza una reunión de hombres trans
para hablar de conocerse e intercambiar
experiencias
y mañana hay un taller que dictó una
endocrinóloga
que dictó en este como el de rabinovich
suite
[Música]
de alguna forma estas fueron mis señales
para mí la transexualidad fue un cambio
enorme en muchos aspectos yo soy una
persona que no le gusta tomar remedios
imagínense una persona que no toma casi
una aspirina y pasa hormonarse
también comencé a hacerme muchas
preguntas
está mal elegir una identidad sexual
distinta
o es preferible engañar a tu familia
toda la vida haciendo alguien que no sos
está bien crear todo un entorno siendo
infeliz haciendo infeliz a todos los que
te rodean
por otro lado cuando te dicen vos
naciste así y no podés modificar tu
cuerpo
cuánta gente se tiñe de rubia y nación
morocha cuánta gente se pone lentes de
contacto de colores en el azul
cuánta gente se tatúa se pone piercings
se hace la nariz se pone siliconas
si lo quiere hacer una persona que
responde a ciertos estereotipos como que
es bisexual heterosexual y otras
características específicas está bien
ahora sí sí es una persona transexual
la que lo hace es tema de debate
si se ponen a pensar es bastante
hipócrita
el día que termina de aceptar mi
identidad fue cuando dije basta
basta de miedos basta de esconderme
basta aparentar
de ser algo que no soy pasta de
vergüenza de lo que soy
a que le tengo miedo
a mostrarme como verdaderamente soy
como soy
qué tipo de persona soy
nadie puede decirte cómo sos
la única persona que sabe realmente como
sos sos vos
nadie más que uno mismo sabe su
verdadera identidad
la persona que uno es no la va a
determinar ni su sexo biológico ni su
identidad de género ni el tipo de
sexualidad que tenga lo que lo va a
definir a uno como persona van a ser sus
acciones como es uno consigo mismo como
es uno con el resto
el género es una construcción social y
cultural
identidad de género es una construcción
personal
sobre esa misma construcción
hay millones de construcciones así como
de personas en el mundo
mi construcción en particular yo voy a
realizar una masculinización de tórax
pero no me voy a hacer una reasignación
de sexo
por qué
porque tiene muchos riesgos
y es por algo de militancia también
yo no me considero menos hombre menos
masculino por el tipo de vitalidad que
tengo
todas estas decisiones puedo tomarlas
hoy gracias a la ley de identidad de
género aprobada en el congreso argentino
en el año 2012
esta ley cubre tanto tratamientos
hormonales como una amplia de
operaciones para adecuar el cuerpo a la
identidad de género autopercibida
esta ley crea derechos ya que cubre a
todos e iguala posibilidades
gracias a esta ley tengo mi nueva
partida de nacimiento mi nuevo dni
que reflejan realmente mi identidad
todavía me acuerdo de la emoción de
cuando los recibí por primera vez me
encantó creo que en lo personal quizás
lo que más me emociona es a la hora que
tengo que firmar algo ya sea que voy a
hacer una compra o que voy a hacer un
trámite estoy firmando y veo reflejado
quién soy realmente
en mi documento anterior me parecía como
esta de otra persona a veces
ahora cuando recuerdo cosas del pasado
las recuerdo desde mi identidad actual
no me sale hacerlo de otra manera
qué bueno sería poder vivir en una
sociedad donde cada uno pueda expresar
más libremente su identidad
sin prejuicios sin limitaciones
sin dudas esta ley marcó un hito
importante en ese sentido
pero fue sólo el principio
viviera en una sociedad más libre más
respetuosa
va a ser un trabajo duro y nos obliga a
abandonar estereotipos
pero qué sigue
no tengo una respuesta exacta
pero estoy seguro de que va a hacer
falta mucho amor
el amor de las familias
el amor que permite sensibilizarnos
aprender a escuchar a estar cerca
a estar atentos a no catalogar
pienso que de esta forma no solo las
personas trans sino todas las personas
vamos a vivir mejor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]